programa número 133 un país tuvo un
gasto total de 1.2 por 10-12 en el año
pasado si la población del país hasta el
año pasado era de 240 millones cuál fue
el gasto per cápita veamos los datos que
nos dan es que es 1.2 por 10 a la 12
que fue el gasto total del país y la
población
es de población
es de 240 millones
estos 240 millones es lo mismo que tener
240 por 10 a las 6 y si este 0 lo
pasamos aquí como exponente vamos a
tener 24 por 10 a las 7
y si recorremos un lugar decimal hacia
la izquierda vamos a tener 2.4 por 10 a
la 8
ahora podemos hacer la división para ver
cuánto fue el gasto porque per cápita o
por cada uno de los habitantes y esto es
1.2 por 10 a la 12 entre la cantidad de
habitantes que lo dejamos como 2.4 por
10 a la 8 aquí dividimos el numerador y
el denominador por 1.2 y nos va a quedar
que es igual a un medio por 10 a la 12
entre 10 a la 8 se van a restar los
exponentes 12 menos 8 es igual a 4 por
10 a la 4 esto es lo mismo que tenés
un medio es punto 5 por 10 a la 4 y esto
es lo mismo que tener 5 por 10 a la 3
que es lo mismo que 5 mil y esta es mi
opción
siguiente problema número 134 cierta
ventana rectangular tiene el doble de
largo que de ancho si su perímetro es de
10 metros cuáles serán sus dimensiones
bueno vamos a dibujarla esta es nuestra
ventana rectangular
vamos a decir que esto de aquí es el
ancho y nos dicen que el largo es el
doble del ancho así que esto será 2a y
nos dicen que el perímetro es de 10
metros
sabemos que el perímetro es la suma de
lo que miden todos los lados y como es
un rectángulo sabemos que este lado es
igual a este va a medir losada y este
lado es igual al de arriba por lo que va
a medir a así que 2 a más 2 a más a más
y va a ser igual al perímetro de 10
metros vamos a sumar todo esto 1 2 3 4 5
por anne es igual a 10 por lo tanto a va
a ser igual a 10 entre 6 podemos dividir
el numerador y denominador entre 2 y
esto nos queda 5 aquí nos queda 35
tercios
y nos dicen que este lado el lado es el
doble d el lado es igual la doble de a
dos por cinco tercios
que es igual a 10 tercios por lo que las
dimensiones de esta ventana el largo y
el ancho van a ser de 10
tercios por 5 tercios
qué es la opción b
siguiente problema
problema número 135 aquí nos muestran
este diagrama medio extraño aquí está el
punto x aquí está el punto y nos dicen
que este diagrama muestra las diferentes
rutas que puede seguir un ratón en un
laberinto para ir de equis allá
rutas hay del punto x al punto y sin
tener que regresar en alguno de estos
puntos vamos a analizarlo
voy a usar ese dibujo que ya tengo acá
veamos de aquí a acá
tengo pues nada más una opción una ruta
aquí puedo ir de este punto este punto
por acá o por acá así que aquí hay dos
rutas lo mismo acá aquí pues pude llegar
a este punto por aquí arriba o por aquí
abajo aquí siguen habiendo dos rutas
a partir de aquí tengo esta ruta y esta
otra ruta para llegar acá aquí ya tenía
dos rutas y voy a explicarlo por estas
otras dos rutas que hay aquí porque
porque para llegar aquí a este punto
pude ir por aquí arriba y luego por aquí
abajo que esta es una pude ir de aquí
arriba por aquí arriba también son dos
rutas pude ir de aquí abajo por aquí
abajo otras rutas y pude ir de aquí
abajo por aquí arriba y hacer en mis
cuatro rutas aquí hay cuatro formas de
llegar a este punto
y aquí acá tenemos una dos tres rutas
esas tres rutas los vamos a multiplicar
por las cuatro anteriores y aquí nos va
a quedar 12 rutas 12 posibles formas de
que el ratoncito pase del punto x al
punto yo y esta opción del 12 es mi
opción c
siguiente problema
problema número 136 si la operación
círculo con punto está definida como x
círculo con punto de igual a raíz
cuadrada de x por jim para todos los
enteros positivos tanto en x como en y
cuál es la solución para 5 círculo con
punto 45 y todo esto círculo con punto
vamos a ver anotemos lo acá esto 5
círculo con punto 45 esto de aquí es
igual a tener la raíz de 5 por 45 la
raíz cuadrada de todo esto aquí está la
definición pero podemos simplificar esto
o reacomodarlo para poder operarlo mejor
y más fácil esto es lo mismo que tener
la raíz cuadrada de 5 por 9 por 5 me da
45 5 por 9 por 5 lo que es lo mismo que
tener la raíz cuadrada de 5 por 5 25 por
9 y que cree en esto lo puedo separar
como la raíz cuadrada de 25 y la raíz
cuadrada de 9 y ambas son es bueno
conozco las raíces cuadradas de esto de
esta va a ser 5 5 por 5 25 y de esta va
a ser 33 por 39
entonces tengo aquí esta parte 3 x 5 15
así que de todo esto
esta operación el resultado es 15 y
ahora lo voy a operar con el círculo
punto 60
de aquí con lo que acabo de tener de
resultado que es 15 círculo punto 60
esto es lo mismo que tener la raíz
cuadrada de 15 x 60 vamos a hacer lo
mismo tratar de descomponer esto para
encontrar algo que tengan alguna raíz
cuadrada exacta si yo multiplico 15 por
4 me va a dar 60 así que esto lo puedo
modificar y dejarlo como 15 por 15 por 4
esto trae es cuadrada de 15 por 15 no
voy a hacer toda la operación porque voy
a sacar la raíz cuadrada y aquí es el
mismo número que se multiplica así que
aquí mismo ya tengo cuál es el resultado
de este esta raíz cuadrada va a ser
igual a 15 y la raíz cuadrada de 4 es 22
por 24 15 por 2 es igual a 30 y este es
mi resultado de toda esta operación
extraña que es mi opción
siguiente problema número 137
encima de un número indica que ese
número se repetirá infinitamente
resuelva esta operación 10 a las cuatro
menos diez a las dos por punto 0 012 y
este 12 tiene la barrita encima así que
este 12 se va a repetir infinitamente en
esta cantidad primero vamos a distribuir
este punto 0 012 en estos dos elementos
tengo
10 4 es 10.000 tengo 1 seguido de cuatro
ceros por punto 0 012
esto va a ser igual a 0 0 0 0 2
1 2 3 4 021
eso es igual a 1 2 3 4 2 1 y tenemos 4
lugares después del punto decimal por lo
que recorremos el punto aquí 1 2 3 4
lugares y me queda 12
la distribución de esto con esto lo que
daría 12 pero no olvidemos que este 12
tenía una barrita encima que dice que se
repite este valor entonces en lugares el
12.000 esto en realidad es 12 puntos 12
12 12 y se repite infinitamente pero
bueno eso vamos a dejarlo así un momento
vamos a hacer lo mismo con este otro
lado el 10 a la 2
es cien por punto 0 012 y esto me va a
dar que es igual a punto 2
de la misma manera que recordamos que es
un 12 con rayita encima este resultado
va a ser
punto 12 12 12 así infinitamente ahora
vamos a tener que restar estas dos
cantidades pues es lo que nos están
indicando aquí así que si tengo
12.12 con rayita para no escribir tanto
menos
0.12 con rayita
si hago esta resta estas cantidades con
la rayita encima que se repiten
infinitamente pues son iguales así que
se van a restar aquí me queda 10 y 12
menos 0 es 12 mi resultado es 12
es la opción
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo